[Musique]
avant de se lancer en politique mon
invité l'a d'abord observé c'était
d'ailleurs son métier et c'est peut-être
ce qui lui a permis ensuite de s'imposer
là où on ne l'attendait pas forcément
[Musique]
bonjour Frédéric valtoux bonjour alors
pendant longtemps les Français vous ont
connu avec une autre casquette que celle
d'homme politique celle de président de
la FHF la Fédération hospitalière de
France de 2011 à 2022 vous étiez un peu
le monsieur hôpital si on peut dire et
ça vous a valu d'être très sollicité
dans les médias notamment on va le voir
pendant toute la période du covid
la mairie de Paris propose un
confinement de trois semaines est-ce que
c'est la bonne solution pour vous vous
pensez qu'il aurait fallu reconfiner dès
aujourd'hui notamment dans ces
territoires jusqu'à quand l'hôpital peut
tenir dans la situation actuelle
qu'est-ce qu'on fait pour améliorer pour
accélérer cette campagne de vaccination
très concrètement on donne plus de
vaccins aujourd'hui les chaînes
logistiques elles existent moi dans ma
ville je pourrais vacciner 4-5 fois plus
de personnes si j'avais 4 fois plus que
4,5 fois plus de vaccins alors c'est un
petit montage qui était là pour montrer
qu'on faisait vraiment interrogé sur
tous les sujets possibles pendant cette
période faut-il confiner déconfiner
reconfiner l'hôpital va-t-il tenir et
même que pensez-vous du professeur
Raoult comment on fait pour répondre à
toutes ces questions quand on n'a pas de
formation médicale qu'on n'a pas été
directeur d'hôpital non plus qu'on est
un ancien journaliste déjà on évacue
toutes les questions qui touchent
vraiment à la médecine j'ai toujours me
suis toujours veillé à ne pas répondre à
des questions qui s'adressaient qui
auraient pu sa fin qui s'adressait
d'abord au médecin que je ne suis pas
que je jamais été et que je n'ai jamais
eu la prétention de remplacer donc par
contre parler de l'organisation des
soins l'organisation de l'hôpital de la
place de l'hôpital en cité de santé
pendant le covid de la des tensions que
vivaient l'hôpital de la manière dont on
pouvait effectivement peut-être mieux
répartir entre les hôpitaux les
cliniques la médecine de ville la
mobilisation de tous ça c'est des
questions aux gères d'organisation qui
en appelaient effectivement d'abord à
sans doute à mon expérience de de mère
parce que les mères donc
les Mercières sont les organes de
gouvernance de l'hôpital dans les
conseils de surveillance des hôpitaux
que moi j'ai présidé mon hôpital depuis
2000-2006 et que c'est d'ailleurs à
travers cette présidence d’hôpital que
j'en suis venu à m'intéresser à la
Fédération speeder de France qui
contrairement à ce qu'on croit n'est pas
toujours composé ni que de directeur ni
que de médecins hospitalier puisque un
tiers du conseil d'administration ce
sont des élus locaux
et ça a toujours été la tradition de
cette fédération présidée par un élu
local des élus et en effet mais souvent
des élus médecins votre prédécesseur
était cardiologue
celui qui vous a succédé était praticien
hospitalier et pendant votre Président
vous avez eu comme adversaire à la fois
Olivier Véran et jean-Louis Touraine
sont les médecins qui sont quand même
des médecins qui a été président de la
FHF certes
de la santé mine de pas médecin et et il
y avait aussi Gérard Larcher qui a
président
des animaux alors voilà il est
vétérinaire mais il est pas médecin non
plus voilà donc si vous voulez c'est
comment vous avez fait pour vous imposer
dans ce milieu quand même médical
hospitalier sans avoir de formation de
compétences il a fallu convaincre les
gens que que vous étiez quand même la
bonne personne malgré tout parce que je
pense que quand on préside une
association que la Fédération
hospitalière qui regroupe tous les
hôpitaux mais aussi tous les EHPAD donc
c'est l'offre de santé publique qui est
au sein de la FHF c'est pas une instance
médicale on n'est pas l'Académie de
médecine c'est avant que la politique
hospitalière
que finalement on est l'interlocuteur
des pouvoirs publics
le gouvernement mais aussi de l'ensemble
de l'écosystème de l'hôpital pour parler
de problématique de financement
d'organisation de liens entre les uns et
les autres la médecine de ville et la
médecine hospitalière de décloisonnement
de l'hôpital on parle avec aussi bien
des architectes sur l'hôpital de demain
que effectivement des médecins parce que
évidemment la dimension médicale est
importante et peut-être que ceux qui ont
voté pour moi pendant toutes ces années
et ils ont vu que ils ont trouvé chez
moi peut-être des qualités de de de
facilitateur entre ces différentes
communautés puisque la communauté
hospitalière elle est plurielle depuis
des professeurs de médecine des plus
grands hôpitaux jusqu'à des médecins
généralistes qui tiennent à bout de bras
des services d'urgence en zone rurale
jusqu'à des élus de différents niveaux
voilà donc il y a une communauté qui est
qui est très très large et puis des
aussi des associations de patients et
peut-être que l'élu c'est celui qui
arrive à faire parler tout le monde je
le disais vous avez eu plusieurs
casquettes pendant 15 ans au début de
votre carrière vous avez été journaliste
journaliste aux échos à la Gazette des
communes également pourquoi est-ce que
vous n'êtes pas lancés en politique dès
le début au bout d'un moment ça m'a
travaillé puisque on passe pas comme ça
du jour on se lève pas un matin en
faisant tiens on va abandonner 15 ans de
carrière professionnelle pour se lancer
dans la dans la politique c'est quelque
chose qui a qui a mûri progressivement
je pense que le lien entre ces deux
moments de ma vie c'est évidemment
l'intérêt pour la chose publique pour
les débats publics pour la chose
politique et je l'ai fait pendant 15 ans
comme observateur comme analyse comme un
modestement à mon niveau mais en tout
cas comme comme bruit comme comme
observateur de de ce qui était la le
débat public et puis un moment j'ai
voulu peut-être être plus acteur
me dire mais finalement le goût de la
poésie doit amener à à franchir le pas
et et être à servir l'intérêt général de
cette manière là et ça vous l'avez fait
en 2001 en défait en mettant sur la
liste aux municipales d'un autre ancien
journaliste télé Jean-François robinet à
Fontainebleau
vous aviez conscience qu'en faisant ça
vous alliez peut-être être amené à
renoncer à votre métier de journaliste
vous y étiez prêt j'avais fait d'abord
en plein accord avec ce qui était qui
est supérieur dans dans le titre que je
servais qui était les échos à l'époque
mais qui était un modeste
rôle de conseillers municipal mais bon
c'est c'est déjà mettre un doigt de pied
dans le sujet
j'avais conscience que ça pouvait
m'emmener plus loin pas vraiment à
l'époque et puis les choses se sont on
va dire précipités dans les années 2000
en 2005 2005 exactement 2005 il y a une
élection partielle à Fontainebleau ça a
été un coup de théâtre cette élection
partielle crise politique locale le
maire d'émission et vous surgissez de
nulle part vous vous imposez
municipal
et vous avez vous êtes imposé une fois
de plus un peu comme à la FHF là où on
vous attendait pas je sais pas moi en
tout cas j'ai peut-être convaincu les
enfin j'ai pas peut-être j'ai compris
puisque j'ai eu la la majorité donc
convaincu les électeurs qu'effectivement
il pouvait me faire confiance peut-être
parce qu'à l'époque j'étais plus jeune
parce que à l'époque j'étais
effectivement un visage nouveau dans la
scène politique locale lequel les choses
ont fonctionné et ça a été pour moi mon
bascule et donc voilà ça fait c'était il
y a 17 18 ans
vous êtes resté maire de Fontainebleau
jusqu'en 2022 jusqu'à votre élection
mais entre les deux vous êtes quand même
présenté deux fois au législative deux
fois en dissidence avec votre famille
politique de l'époque qui était l'UMP
vous étiez engagé à droite on dirait pas
comme ça mais derrière votre côté
toujours souriant jovial finalement il y
a un rebelle candidat dissident à deux
reprises à rebelle je sais pas d'abord
je voudrais dire que j'ai été élu la
première fois sans étiquette politique
et c'est ensuite que je j'ai toujours
été deux centres droits d'affinités
voilà donc mais très européen et mais
j'avais pas d'étiquette poétique bien
sûr quand je faisais journaliste je je
militais absolument pas c'était pas le
sujet ensuite effectivement après mon
élection j'ai rejoint les rangs UMP mais
c'était à l'époque où l'UMP était la
promesse d'être un CDI ou à la française
avec un courant gaulliste un courant
libéral et aussi un comportement
démocrates allemands c'était voilà la
maison commune de la droite et du centre
ce qu'on connaît l'histoire et
finalement l'histoire ça n'a pas été
celle-là et progressivement cette maison
s'est rétractée mais au début c'était ça
mon pour ça que je rejoins cette maison
et le rebelle alors le rebelle c'est
simplement que j'étais personnellement
quand vous avez passé le destin
peut-être d'essayer de mettre le pied
dans la porte quand on n'est pas invité
à la table du bancaire mais
en tous les cas bon voilà c'est c'est
aussi la foule de de de la jeunesse en
politique j'étais pas très jeune j'avais
une quarantaine d'années mais enfin
j'étais jeune dans le dans le dans le
dans l'élection donc c'est peut-être
enthousiasme là qui m'a donné envie et
puis parce que je voyais bien aussi que
le levier à l'époque on parlait du
député-mercq levier député maire
lorsqu'on avait en charge une ville
finalement avec peu de moyens mais qui
avait de grandes ambitions pouvaient
être un levier d'action supplémentaire
pour mieux servir effectivement j'ai vu
pendant des années que le député qui du
coup m'avait battu me mettait des bâtons
dans les roues donc j'ai bien vu que
finalement il y avait là intérêt à avoir
effectivement aussi le levier national
pour aider au départ en une ville vous
parliez de l'enthousiasme que vous avez
eu à l'époque sur ces deux législatives
en 2022 ça semblait être un peu moins le
cas vous êtes allé un peu à reculons
c'est l'impression que ça donne en tout
cas bah oui vous êtes présenté sous les
couleurs d'horizon donc cette fois donc
la formation politique d'Édouard
Philippe assez tardivement et en disant
j'ai toujours considéré que la fonction
de mer était plus passionnante et
concrète sous-entendu que celle de
député vous aviez visiblement pas une
très haute idée de ce mandat est-ce que
vous avez changé d'avis depuis alors
d'abord je l'ai fait avec envie puisque
finalement j'y suis allé oui mais je
rappelle que les investisseurs ont été
donnés après la présidentielle donc
moins tant que je n'avais pas
d'investiture je je je n'en parlais pas
mais si vous êtes plus donné
l'impression que je me je j'y allais
peut-être sans enthousiasme après c'est
vrai que je pense et je continue à le
penser que la fonction de maire est la
plus riche la plus épanouissante et
finalement la plus concrète aussi dans
les mandats que du monde politique c'est
vrai que c'est éminemment concret vous
touchez à la vie de vos concitoyens de
la jusqu'à malheureusement la mort avec
la gestion du cimetière et des affaires
funéraires donc finalement à tous les
âges de la vie vous retrouvez vos
concitoyens croise le maire ces services
et c'est évidemment concret passionnant
Fontainebleau en plus je vais pas là je
suis pas là pour faire l'article sur
Fontainebleau mais c'est une ville qui
est passionnante si vous avez trouvé
votre place à l'Assemblée
là vous êtes plus que 1 par 1560 vous
êtes pas seuls aux commandes comme vous
l'avez été à Fontainebleau moi je me
suis engagé derrière un homme Édouard
Philippe parce qu'il était dans un
parcours qui m'intéressait et parce que
depuis le début on se connaît et on a
beaucoup échangé sur les choix récents
qu'il a fait de créer horizon et de
s'engager je l'ai fait aussi pour ça je
l'ai fait pour continuer à servir bien
sûr le sud Seine-et-Marne des fontaines
lots et je l'ai fait parce que c'était
aussi l'occasion pour moi de plonger gr
dans dans les problématiques dans les
dossiers nationaux dans les enjeux
nationaux et ce que j'ai trouvé ma place
c'est un poteau pour le dire et puis on
voit que dans la dans le contexte
politique de l'Assemblée trouver sa
place il y a pas de place très stable on
le voit puisque tout bouge tout le temps
d'un mot juste
réalité en préparant cette émission
j'étais surpris de découvrir il y a très
peu de choses écrites sur vous qui vous
racontent très peu de portraits
contrairement à la plupart des députés
pourquoi c'est-à-dire que vous vous
aimez pas vous confier vous méfiez des
journalistes non je me méfie pas des
journalistes d'avoir en plus je suis
porte-parole de mon groupe donc je suis
amené beaucoup j'aime pas trop parler de
moi je le fais mais pourquoi c'est
d'offrir des prises à vos adversaires
phénoménal maintenant après c'est mon
avis mais je peux parler de moi c'est
pas un problème j'ai rien de particulier
à cacher mais simplement bon là je pense
que quand on fait de la politique c'est
pas pour parler de soi ou c'est pour
être dans l'accès dans l'action et puis
de voilà on va passer notre quiz à
présent si vous le voulez bien le
principe je vous explique je vais
commencer des phrases et ça va être à
vous de les compléter on y va les
journalistes politiques devraient
devrait veiller à posséder une culture
politique qui leur permettrait de
comprendre le temps long de manière à
pouvoir
concilier à la fois présent dans
l'instant présent mais aussi la
compréhension qu'il y a des lignes de
force de longue durée et qui souvent
permet d'expliquer un certain nombre de
choses en 2027 Edouard Philippe sera
candidat à la présidentielle en tout cas
moi je le souhaite
président
de la République on fera tout pour mais
déjà candidat ça serait une belle étape
un bon ministre de la santé doit pas
forcément être un docteur parce que il y
a on est dans un secteur où les
corporatismes sont importants et on le
voit dès qu'on veut faire bouger les
lignes ça peut mais du coup peut-être on
met rarement un agriculteur à la tête du
ministère de l'agriculture et les
exemples pourraient être nombreux pas de
militaire à la tête du ministère de la
Défense donc c'est pourquoi il faut
mieux cacher des corporatismes ça c'est
la première chose et puis un bon
ministre de la santé doit être quelqu'un
qui doit être
pas capable d'être un peu volontariste
et audacieux parce que s'il y a bien un
secteur des politiques publiques qui n'a
qui est quand même très sclérosée c'est
bien les politiques de santé donc en
fait là c'est votre portrait que vous
venez de dresser pas forcément un petit
peu quand même ça vous intéresse si
jamais beaucoup de gens qui connaissent
bien les sujets qui sont pas des
professionnels de santé ça fait partie
de vos ambitions de venir un jour
ministre de la Santé on verra ça
là-dessus je sais pas d'Edouard Philippe
peut-être
merci beaucoup en tout cas Frédéric
Valto d'être venu dans la politique et
merci
[Musique]